Let me suggest that the phrase "human activity" is a common factor that connects all the disciplines together...
...under the umbrella of environmental science.
What do I mean by this?
Well, as I mentioned before, the earth sciences and environmental science overlap to some extent.
Both of them deal with process and change in our natural environment.
However, environmental science is principally concerned with changes made by human activity...
...and the subsequent implications for the ecosphere.
So, environmental science exists as a body of knowledge where specialists work together...
...to address a particular problem that has been created by human activity.
This separates it from the earth sciences, which focus on process and change...
...within the natural environment without the added factor of human intervention.
Let me illustrate this by giving you a brief example of how environmental scientists work together.
Perhaps there is a problem over building new homes on a flood plain.
There would be a comprehensive study of the issue to try and find a viable solution,...
...and it would draw on a wide range of disciplines.
It would involve the mapping of the solid geology of the rock underneath the proposed site.
The scientists would identify the overlying sediments, measure and trace the flow and movement of water,...
...and sample and record the species living in and around the site.
The study would engage scientists from a wide range of disciplines,...
...but their collaboration and focus on the effects of human activity...
...would identify them as environmental scientists.
So, to summarize, environmental science is the branch of biology concerned...
...with the relationships between organisms and their environment,...
...and the effect of human actions on these systems.
Thank you and this concludes our lecture today.